[Music]
this is furuco lamborghini he was a
prisoner of war-torn successful business
owner in 1963 when he went to get his
ferrari 250 gt fixed
enzo ferrari called him a farmer who
didn't know anything about
[Music]
lamborghini then went on to start one of
the most epic car companies in the world
over the past 50 years lamborghini has
firmly established itself as one of the
most desirable and respected brands in
the automotive industry
lamborghini emerged from unlikely
beginnings and has survived through
great financial upheaval
in the process lamborghini has given the
world some of the most insane and iconic
cars in recent memory
and it all started after being told he
was just a farmer by enzo ferrari
[Music]
in 1916 ferruccio lamborghini was born
on a farm in a rural town in northern
italy his parents were grape farmers and
made wine for a living they raised him
in the vineyards even at a young age
they taught him the importance of hard
work and making quality a number one
priority farucco took their lessons to
heart but not in the way that they had
hoped for or imagined he was more
technically minded and was more
interested in repairing their tractors
than learning how to grow grapes and
manage the farm his family was
disappointed in him as they thought it
was risky for him to stray from the
family business
still he chose to explore his passion
and studied mechanics at a technical
institute
after graduating he started training
with a master blacksmith who shared all
of his ironworking and welding secrets
but it wasn't enough to impress a major
factory that he had his eyes set on
at the time the factory worked on
maintaining the italian army's vehicles
through grit and determination he
persisted and managed to convince the
owner to hire him
when he turned 18 he left and returned
to his hometown and opened a workshop
with his longtime friend mariano
filipina it wasn't until years later
that he would discover it was the first
step towards turning his passion into an
empire
but first he would have to escape the
clutches of his captors when the second
world war hit he was drafted by the
royal italian air force and was assigned
to work as a mechanic at the garrison in
rhodes an island in greece
three years later italy surrendered
afterwards the german forces took over
the garrison and evicted the italians
ferruccio decided to stay and ask for
permission to open up his own workshop
in 1945 the allied forces arrived they
took everyone in the garrison as
prisoners
including ferruccio when he was a
prisoner of war they discovered his
technical aptitude they got him to fix
their vehicles and military equipment
one year later they allowed him to leave
[Applause]
ferruccio was met with misfortune when
he returned to italy his wife clelia
passed away while giving birth to their
only child tornino
afterwards ferruccio kept himself busy
at his workshop where he mostly fixed
pre-war vehicles lorries and tractors
but one day he received an urgent
request from his father that changed the
course of his life
his father needed a new tractor it was
at that moment ferruccio had an epiphany
italy desperately needed to increase its
agricultural production to recover from
the war but it needed better equipment
to make that possible armed with
experience in working with allied and
access vehicles
he brought leftover military equipment
and used them to make new tractors they
were built with old british morris
engines and modified to run on cheap
diesel instead of expensive petrol they
were said to be more affordable and
innovative than any other tractor later
he started a new company called
lamborghini tractors while his tractors
were in demand he needed more capital
for production so his father used his
farm as collateral for a loan
the risk ferruccio and his father took
paid dividends
soon after the company found massive
success and became one of the largest
manufacturers of its kind in italy
ferruccio celebrated his success by
living a more extravagant lifestyle
champagne caviar and fast cars
he even started to collect jaguars
mercedes maseratis and ferraris but none
of them completely satisfied him he was
particularly disappointed with his
ferrari 250 gt since the clutch would
always break down
one day he brought his ferrari down to
the mechanic for repairs
he then found out that the clutch was
identical to the one fitted onto one of
his tractors this didn't sit well with
him since he paid 10 euros for the
clutch his tractor used and paid ferrari
1 000 euros for the same part later he
decided to tell enzo ferrari the founder
of ferrari about the imperfections he
found in his car along with the clutches
needing frequent repairs they were
considered too noisy and rough on the
road
ferruccio was just trying to give advice
to enzo on how to improve his car so it
would drive better but enzo simply said
you're a tractor driver you're a farmer
you shouldn't complain about my cars
because they're the best cars in the
world
that infuriated ferruccio and he was
determined to prove enzo wrong
many called his conquest crazy and
thought he'd waste his fortune still he
went ahead and started a new company
under his own name
he hired three of ferrari's ex-employees
and bought a large plot of land to build
a factory
in just nine months he completed his
first sports car featuring his
astrological sign as the emblem the
lamborghini 350 gt was born it was
considered a technical masterpiece and
included a v12 engine five-speed
transmission four-wheel disc brakes and
four-wheel independent suspension
it was unveiled for the first time at
the turin motor show and praised by
customers and critics his first car was
described as sophisticated and classy it
was also easy to drive
he proved to enzo and his doubters that
he wasn't just a farmer but also a
mechanical genius capable of building
superior cars
over the next few years his tractor and
sports car business flourished his
leadership style led to his team
building the 400 gt and a secret project
the miura p400 it was developed as a
street race car and was the first car in
history to be made with a rear mid
engine layout
the development of the mural was
actually kept a secret from ferruccio
since he wasn't a big fan of street race
cars as he'd been involved in a crash
before
when ferruccio found out he decided not
to scrap the idea it turned out to be
one of the best decisions he ever made
the miura became known as the world's
first supercar and its rear mid-engine
layout became the standard for all high
performance cars from then on
lamborghini continued its successful
streak and debuted more celebrated
models such as the espada the aslero the
hamara the uruko and the kuntash they
were said to be superior to other sports
cars since they didn't use anyone else's
parts and the countach was said to be
the most written about car in history
unfortunately his success came to a halt
after facing a series of events beyond
his control a deal to supply bolivia
with 5 000 tractors was cancelled after
the country faced a coup the loss forced
him to sell his tractor company and 51
percent of his lamborghini shares the
global stock market experienced a
dramatic crash and opec started an oil
embargo it led to increased fuel prices
and threw the automotive industry into
turmoil ferruccio did his best to keep
his business alive and managed to find
buyers for his unsold tractors still he
decided to retire early and sold the
remaining 49 of his lamborghini shares
but he did keep a heating company that
he owned and gave it to his son tonino
later tonino pivoted towards building a
successful fashion and luxury business
under the family name
meanwhile the new owners of lamborghini
tried to revive its brand but failed
afterwards the company was forced into
liquidation a few years later the
italian government sold it for three
million to two french billionaires they
hoped to renovate the old lamborghini
facilities and hire new engineers but
they ran out of money and sold the
company to chrysler chrysler made plans
to import the brand into the us but
failed to make a profit so they sold to
the company megatech an indonesian
conglomerate
while they had more luck in making sales
it wasn't enough to weather the
financial crisis in asia it was then
that audi bought the company and
recognized the need for greater
attention to processes and production
quality
under their leadership lamborghini was
able to meet the challenges of the 21st
century and took back its place in the
market with the release of the
murcielago gallardo aventador huracan
and the earth's sales jumped across the
world especially in the us in 2019
lamborghini reported record sales and
was valued at 11 billion
lamborghini is still one of the most
epic car brands in the world and has
built some of the most iconic cars over
the years and it all started because
enzo ferrari called ferruccio
lamborghini a farmer
this is the story of how a prisoner of
war turned his tractor business into a
supercar empire
so what can we learn from ferruccio
lamborghini's success
there's a lesson in every story and
lamborghini's is definitely an inspiring
one he went against his parents advice
to pursue his passion he honed his
mechanical engineering skills and
leveraged them to build his companies
but the most important lesson from
lamborghini's story is to use anger as
motivation
he used enzo's disrespect as motivation
to build his car company
driven to prove all his doubt is wrong
he started a brand that has cemented his
legacy and name in history
thanks for staying till the end of this
video if you enjoyed this video then be
sure to hit the like button drop a
comment subscribe and hit the
notification bell for more content like
this
also be sure to check out our other
videos on this channel links are in the
description and we'll see you in the
next one